[Music]
here in this video we are going to
analyze the full anatomy of mecha
godzilla from the monsterverse
or simply put its design workings and
powers and also how it was made
and what makes it move the way it does
this is a mechanical titan that appears
in the 2021 legendary pictures film
godzilla vs kong it is the second
incarnation of mecca godzilla to appear
in an american made film
after the incarnation featured in the
film ready player one
so if you're interested in this video
then do hit that like button
and also subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family and now let's get down
with this
of course we are going to start with the
size of this mecca
mechagodzilla is one of the largest
titans in the most of the second tallest
of the
ginkidora as gong was 337 feet tall and
godzilla was around 393 feet in height
mechagodzilla towered over these two
titans and was easily around 450 feet in
height
even though official statistics haven't
been released this would have put him
over 50 feet taller than godzilla but
still 70 feet shy of mars to zero
his length would have been over 900 feet
as he was bigger than godzilla
which was 850 feet long and since he was
designed to look exactly like the king
of the monsters
he would have been somewhere around the
900 feet range in length
head to tail that is this mecha godzilla
is much slimmer than the previous
incarnations of the character
mechagodzilla's exoskeleton is a bright
gun metal silver tone with
tiny touches of black and with vivid
neon red energy
glow radiating from the holes in his
armored metal plates
across his body the neck of the
mechagodzilla
is ripped and lined with cybernetic
gills while its abdomen resembles a
ribcage
mechagodzilla's back supports three rows
of small square
shaped dorsal blades the edges of which
are
akin to axle blades it also has a long
segmented tail with a set of small twin
blades at the tip
which can spin like a drill the mecha
has a very strange but super durable
metal alloy
that acts as its armor it would have
probably been some
new titanium alloy since it was able to
warp through buildings unscathed
and with no scratches at all regarding
its arms and legs
mechagodzilla seems to have very long
arms as they are seen to be kinda
humanoid in proportion to its body
the legs too looks to be longer in
comparison to those of godzilla
the mech's arms and hands are
considerably larger and thicker in
comparison to the rest of its body
and the armored plating on its arms and
legs are very very
very scary to look at it has sharp claws
that look like claw cranes and with
little razor sharp circular saws at the
bottom of each finger
and there are also black absorbent parts
on the tips it contains four submission
launchers hidden under its shoulder pads
and his feet
more specifically its toes bear striking
resemblance to those of master zero
now let's look at its head it resembles
that of godzilla
of course but looks small crude and
steampunk in design
with eyes that have a bright glow above
them the reddish glow of the eyes don't
seem to be much of use other than for
intimidation
we were expecting laser beams to shoot
off out of them but
sadly that wasn't the case it had a
robust and rectangular
shaped snout with no nose obviously as
it was a robot and it did not need the
sense of smell
the mouth has no teeth but it has metal
protrusions and
buzz saws that can cut through titan
heights the mouth
though can shoot the protons cream beam
they can slice through
anything but a tough tightened skin
now that we have explained in detail
about the outer body let's go into the
inner workings of the mech
it's anatomy it would be safe to say
that the mecca
has no internal organs as it has no need
for such
basically it's just one big nuclear
reactor in case inside a weapon system
that includes both
melee and unconventional weaponry i
think the torso of the titan is where
the main reactor goes plays
just like those of gypsy danger in
pacific rim
so the main reactor co is placed inside
his torso but it also has secondary
power
units in its shoulders arms legs
even the head and as well as the tail
the power system would
also utilize it also placed as
capacitors or
batteries that can direct energy
directly to the proton stream that is
situated in the throat of the mecca
and thus allowing the weapon to be shut
from the mouth now with the upgrade of
the hollow earth power source
apex was able to power the robot
indefinitely
so how does one even imagine controlling
a 450 foot tall mecca with unlimited
energy
of course a human alone would not be
able to do it since it would be equal to
subconsciously
and consciously be one with the machine
therefore there was need of an ai
an artificial intelligence or maybe a
supercomputer with
a specially designed algorithm now comes
the part of
integrating guidora's brain with the
mecha for such a purpose
and allowing a neural interface for a
user like ren serizawa
to pilot supervisors and control the
mecca like a flight simulation machine
but there was need of two guitars had to
be linked to one another
so one for the pilot which apex had
converted into a living supercomputer
with a neural interface
in the station and another one that was
placed in mechagodzilla's head
unfortunately once the consciousness of
guido took over control
once it had its unlimited energy and
since there was no need for humans
anymore
the mecca went on a rampage now
all this was designed and created in
order to fire the weapons of the mecca
as this was created to be the titan
killing weapon system
firstly to put on scream is a red beam
of pure energy that
mechagodzilla can focus and discharge
from its mouth thanks to a system of
lenses that assemble
inside his throat it was powerful enough
to chop through
huge skull crawlers in half when used at
just 40
power and once mecha godzilla was fueled
by the hollow earth energy it was
unstoppable
mechagodzilla has two 16 cell missile
launchers which rise from behind its
shoulder pads
it also has a set of six rocket boosters
that fire out of
openable parts from its dorsal fins
these boosters make mecha godzilla more
agile in close quarters combat
regarding its melee weapons make a
godzilla is equipped with crane light
claws rather than the claws that
resemble godzilla's fingers
the interiors of these claws are done
with industrial bus saws that sear
through the flesh of even godzilla as it
was about to deliver
the kiss of death the tail is equipped
with two fin-like blades
that can be formed into a drill that it
attempted to use against godzilla and
kong
spinning in high rpms and since it was
titanium
it would have easily stabbed kong and
maybe even godzilla
but when not in use it falls into a
blade remarkably similar to the unisot
featured in the tale of the show
incarnation of the character
so that's about all that we have on the
monsterverse mecca
pubg also introduced the abilities of
swimming
using the thrusters and launching small
drones which
i don't know if they can be considered
canon to the character
but anyway that's all we have and so
with that we come to the end of the
video
do hit that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
monster family
and also hit that bell button for
regular updates on monster content right
here on this channel
till the next one take care fam